do you remember when public companies
were putting bitcoin on their balance
sheet first we had microstrategy then
tesla and square well let's go take a
little update as to how that's going so
far as we know it all started with
microstrategy in august of 2020. they
spent just under 4 billion
to date and they've bought up about 130
000 bitcoin tesla and square they've
bought much less but they still spent
hundreds of millions to just over a
billion and a half dollars to buy their
bitcoin as well in a recent article on
block works we see that tesla they
acquired 43 200 bitcoin for about 1.5
billion dollars that's now only worth
844 million which represents a 655
million dollar paper loss now this is a
minuscule part of their balance sheet as
they have about 17.55 billion in cash
and cash equivalents as of march 31st
then we can take a look over at block
which is formerly known as square
they've lost about 30 of their bitcoin
the company reported 8027 bitcoin which
they purchased for 220 million dollars
it's now worth 157 million which is 63
million dollars in unrealized losses
again a minuscule amount as their
balance sheet has 5.3 billion in cash on
hand
and then lastly we have microstrategy
microstrategy which has billions of
dollars of bitcoin on their balance
sheet they're down about 36 percent on
their bitcoin if we take a look and we
compare these stocks to bitcoin and the
nasdaq 100 we can see that everything is
down that's a function of monetary
policy leading to tighter financial
conditions we can see both that block
and microstrategy are down more than
bitcoin but tesla still hugging closer
to the nasdaq 100
this isn't just these three companies
though as we take a look there's a
number of other businesses that have
purchased quite a bit of bitcoin and
this chart shows exactly how much they
purchased it for and what their current
unrealized losses are as you see at the
top microstrategy bought 3.98 billion
dollars worth of bitcoin now they are
sitting on a 1.44 billion dollar
unrealized loss
tesla sitting on about 650 million
dollar unrealized loss as well
and so if we take a look at all of the
companies that have bought bitcoin you
can see here in this next chart if you
take a look here you can see that it's
microstrategy tesla block but there's
also many others some of these are
bitcoin mining companies some of them
are crypto related and some are just
businesses that want to hold bitcoin on
their balance sheet naturally the haters
the critics and those who have been
screaming that bitcoin is worthless
they're taking victory laps on the
internet right now
but one thing should sit in your mind
is these companies full of thousands of
employees some with very large finance
teams they aren't selling their bitcoin
yes they acquired bitcoin and it is down
in an unrealized lost position
they're underwater on that bitcoin on
their balance sheet but none of them out
of microstrategy tesla and block have
actually sold their bitcoin in fact
microstrategy's been buying more and
tesla and block are simply holding it
don't listen to what people say just
watch what people with skin in the game
are doing and they're not selling which
tells me that they've got long-term
conviction in this strategy now of
course it doesn't feel good to have
unrealized losses and some of the
accounting rules for public companies
aren't exactly friendly in these
situations
but what we know is that these companies
they all are led by people who have a
deep conviction in bitcoin as a
decentralized digital currency they went
ahead and they took the capital off
their balance sheet they converted some
of it into bitcoin and they're holding
you could even argue that these three
publicly traded companies they have
diamond hands they're gonna hold through
the volatility they're not selling no
matter how low the price goes or how big
the unrealized losses get and that's
something that i think a lot of people
in the bitcoin community would commend
the conviction is deep
and the thinkers are long-term oriented
bitcoin sits on the balance sheet of
many public companies
and the largest purveyors of this
strategy
they seem to be unfazed by the drop in
bitcoin's price
that
likely will prove to be a great strategy
over a long period of time
bitcoin's volatile goes up a lot it goes
down a lot but over a long period of
time it continues to gain value against
the us dollar my guess is that
shareholders over that period of time
are going to be very happy that their
leadership went ahead and made these
decisions even if in the short term it
ain't looking so hot hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time